e aí galera caso ronaldo com vocês
ninguém está tudo uma maravilha só não
está melhor porque eu não passei o meu
dia dos pais com meu pai e um filho tão
triste kaká
ei ei eu fiquei tão triste porque as
pessoas discrimina os pais discrimino do
dia das mães é a maior o time ninguém
anda na rua e ninguém e ninguém anda na
rua ou do mundo comprando presente para
mim em todo mundo a pessoa no meio da
rua comprar o presente da mãe em outro
dia se eiko tanto pela questão
presenteie o que comprar para a minha
mãe chega em casa mãe a campeã foi a
senhora tampouco da velha cadê meu filho
não seja nada é cara porque não pode
coisa cíntia adoro as coisas cara adora
quando abri o oita lá um carro meu filho
não precisava meu deus um siena queria
um corolla mas tudo bem me dancing o fim
vai lá vende o ceni cobrou das 6 horas
da manhã fui acorda faz o café da manhã
gostoso com a marca linda do mundo leva
na cama bom dia no mãe feliz dia das
mães amanhã
ai filho brincar dançar música mãe
hoje eu descobri que eu te amo e no dia
dos pais numa ninguém frita um ovo com o
pai ele espera receber um feliz dia dos
pais que o presente é 6 gravata vamos
comprar um sapato não gere não dá pra
comprar sapato a família se fosse a mãe
comprar uma perna da carmen steffens dá
pra ela eu acho engraçado que o pai da
gente e não sabe na e paz eu vi o meu
chinelo que nela na verdade ou não o
chinelo no pé dele e ele passa o dia
todo em calçadas quem tá procurando ver
quando ele percebe que está gostando do
pé ele tira bota lá no pé da porta e
esse ano aqui deixo ela para a parte 1
tem vergonha na tua cara meio não é
rapaz fica procurando não acha foi
música quem já que faz música para a
página só tem uma música papai que a do
filme spy você foi meu herói
mantido hoje mais muito mais que um
amigo e você pode prestar atenção a
homenagem do dia dos pais no facebook
não passa de 4 linha agora vê o dia da
mãe da menina a redação do enem é 25 é
contada eo povo ainda ficam brigando e
protestou teve 123 fazendo não envio de
20 c e para ainda hoje é de tal meu pai
lá no the lisbon ad escreve mais te amo
mãe muito pra sempre você é a pessoa
mais interessante que existe na terra
mãe é obrigado pela la para que você me
deu de mamar duas linhas só para ganhar
do texto do outro vez que a mãe nem
alfabetizar sarney e não se inscrever
que todo meu facebook tem saber que eu
amo a minha mãe com isso me ajuda a
levantar se soltava maria mãe fala só
fazer nada nada me livre am
mãe eu te amo tanto começo do meu jardim
aí vai a oposto da foto com o pai no dia
dos pais meu guerreiro meu parceiro tamo
junto é nóis pai de neymar e toy a mãe
contar com o fogo estava com vontade de
comer um jerimum verde africana que
nasce na tailândia ele resolve em cima
de um cavalo mas vai com tudo em cima de
terra demais todo lugar para arranjar o
tire mundo verifica na áfrica dá ainda
caro [__] at acha que dá para o pai
que ninguém tira uma manga com o país
vai tomar que o amanhã que faltem você
tem que dar valor o pai de vocês que
você tem que dar valor a esse cara que
por meu pai o meu pai faria tudo por mim
meu pai é um homem que puxa meu pai é
meu guerreiro meu parceiro temos um é
nóis é nóis fumo é bom meu pai faria
tudo meu pai da yoko por mim
oi oi pai pai é pai o senhor daria o
corpo por mim o senhor daria pouco por
mim se o daronco por mim e oco
eu tô gravando o vídeo dia dos pais
mandar um abraço para todos os pais que
está me assistindo agora é obrigatório
por lei é dos pais e meu pai meu pai e
eu infelizmente não pude estar com meu
pai que estava trabalhando viajando a
fazer show atenção para propaganda dia
15 em joão pessoa 22/23 campina grande
natal 28 de agosto barueri são paulo 29
de agosto em campinas são paulo 30 de
agosto vinhedo são paulo 5 de setembro
crato ceará 77 em petrolina 7 juazeiro
bahia dia 18 de setembro teresina piauí
muito obrigado a desistir de vir até
aqui clicar em gosto e já me ajuda
demais volta lá no facebook aposta de
curtir marcam um amigo seu o pai matou o
próprio pai é interessante pagar a
inscrever no canal para não depender de
um vídeo novo valeu é nóis e b e
produtiva pitico valeu tal